so the lab in Wuhan was unsafe that was
obvious to Americans visiting there two
years ago and because of the practices
there the Chinese may have unleashed a
global pandemic on the rest of us here's
something remarkable and upsetting the
work in that lab including its research
into disease carrying bats was funded in
part by you by US taxpayers through the
National Institutes of Health hard to
believe that's true but it is Congress
Matt Gaetz represents Florida he joins
us tonight to follow up on this story
congressman that's one of those stories
that if you had said that out loud a
week ago I think even I might have
dismissed you as insane but it's true
how did this happen
yeah I'm against funding Chinese
research in our country but I'm sure
against funding it in China the NIH
gives this three point seven million
dollar grant to the Wuhan Institute of
biology
they then advertise that they need
coronavirus researchers following that
coronavirus erupts in Wuhan and then
what's really troubling to me is that
either conspicuously or miraculously the
Wuhan Institute of biology is able to
sequence the virus on January 2nd but
China doesn't admit to the virus
existing to January 9th and then the
Wuhan Institute of Eire ology doesn't
release this important scientific
information to the world until January
12th so at best
Americans are funding people who are
lying to us and at worst were funding
people who we knew had problems handling
pathogens who then birthday monster
virus onto the world by the way China is
about to eclipse us in terms of the size
of its economy if it hasn't already and
it seems like it already may have either
way why would it be sending any money to
China for any purpose there is a far too
cozy relationship between US research
and Chinese research because there are
some research institutions in our
country who realize the short-term
benefit of Chinese cash but that doesn't
excuse our government and what should
really trouble viewers is that this is
an active grant this isn't something of
yesteryear and so I've called on
secretary a czar to immediately halt
this grant to the
Institute of Ayala gee they have not
been honest and at worst
they've been negligent to the point of
many many deaths throughout the world
this will live on for all time as a
metaphor for our incompetence and
self-loathing it looks like there is
evidence that this virus escaped from
the lab we don't know that that happened
but it's not a crazy supposition and now
it turns out we were funding the lab do
you think just about a mine it for us
that someone can end the funding to the
Wuhan is to the virology if we can't do
that I mean really well well I believe
that secretary a czar can do it with the
stroke of a pen and certainly it is
consistent with the fantastic news that
President Trump gave us today that the
United States is no longer going to be a
patsy for these America last
organizations like the w-h-o and the WTO
we've been taken advantage of in those
globalist infrastructures for far too
long under both Republicans and
Democrats President Trump gives us the
chance to liberate ourselves from this
and to put our people our health and our
economy first that would be nice
congressman gates thanks so much for
coming on appreciate it thanks Tucker